Building Java projects are relatively
simple when compared to
Android projects.
It is still a multi step process
that we prefer to automate.
Gradle provides full support for
Java projects.
To include compiling our sources,
creating a jar file,
generating documentation,
running test, and creating reports.
Gradle models the java build
process by creating tasks for
each of these steps and wiring up
the necessary dependencies for us.
A typical Java build will usually
involve compiling our source code and
processing resources.
And packaging those resources and
Java class files into a jar.
It can also include test code,
which will need to be compiled, and
then the tests run themselves.
Optionally a Java project may also
include generating Java docs or
packaging source jars.
Gradle also creates lifecycle tasks for
us.
Describe common build outputs
like assembling our artifacts.
Running project checks or
doing a complete build.
All this functionality is
provided by free Gradle,
in the form of a plug-in,
which can be applied to to your project.
Now let's take a look at how to
add a Java plug-in to our build.